non
ah non d'accord on a travaillé depuis un
mois et même davantage sur ce plan de
relance puisqu'il ya un certain nombre
de points que vous avez pu voir déjà
dans les propositions les vpn mais
damien il reviendra dans quelques
instants qui ont été présentées à
l'assemblée dans les différents
amendements qu'on a pu porter le travail
de fond que l'on fait dans nos dans nos
forums
mais au-delà de ça il ya deux choses qui
nous semblent essentielles tout d'abord
que ce plan de relance arrive très
rapidement
nous sommes plusieurs à être intervenue
auprès du gouvernement pour ne pas
tarder parce que on voit bien que pour
des entreprises
l'essentiel c'est d'avoir de la
lisibilité dans dans l'action quand on
est chef d'entreprise on a besoin d'y
voir clair sur ce que va être la
stratégie et l'action du gouvernement
or tarder sur le plan de relance ou le
distribuer secteur par secteur le
saucissonner je crois que ce n'est pas
une ça n'est pas une bonne chose est en
tout cas ça ne confonds pas la confiance
ni la lisibilité de l'action publique le
deuxième élément qui était important
pour nous pour aller vite sur ce plan de
relance c'est que la france
malheureusement à aborder cette crise
sanitaire dans une situation économique
et budgétaire très très fragile un jeu
je reprends pas les chiffres que que
vous connaissez mais quand on regarde
que ce soit sur le déficit on a le pire
déficit de la zone euro c'est là c'est
la france l'endettement qui a explosé
dans des proportions plus importantes
que beaucoup de pays le record européen
des prélèvements des prélèvements
obligatoires le pire déficit commercial
d'europe 1 des taux de croissance les
plus faibles de l'union européenne la
réalité c'est tout cela parce que ces
trois ans ont été gâchées au sens où il
ya eu aucune réforme de structure qui
ont été réalisées pendant ces trois
années donc ça nous met effectivement
dans une situation plus compliquée que
d'autres pays donc nous avons voulu
l'axé autour d'eux
5 5 priorités qui sont sains sûrs qu'on
appelait sauver nos entreprises et nos
et nos emplois l'idée là elle est d'être
sûr sur une année blanche un peu partie
des propositions qu'on a souvent souvent
évoquée plutôt que de faire du report de
charges
moi j'ai ce souvenir lorsque j'étais au
ministère des pme
si on maintient d entreprise à flot
jamet arrive à redémarrer donc il y à un
moment il vaut mieux faire une année
blanche qui permet de redémarrer de
redonner de l'oxygène et ensuite on
retrouve plus rapidement une performance
que l'on n'a pas si on maintient coup de
dead mois par par mois il ya ensuite la
mesure sur le chômage partiel qui est
d'une très bonne mesure qui a bien
marché
ceci étant une barge bien si on en sort
aussi et donc il ya la nécessité de la
maintenir sur un certain nombre de
secteurs mais il faut en sortir et
transformé l'aide publique qui est fait
dans cette mesure de chômage partiel sur
de là sur la baisse de charge
c'est-à-dire pour aller sur l'incitation
à l'emploi
la suppression de la c3 est ce que l'on
propose également s'inscrit dans la
logique suivante c'est le type d'impôt
ou en fait on commence à payer avant
même d'avoir produit un euro de chiffre
d'affaires on est sur un financement un
impôt d'état donc ça ne sonne en di
kappa les collectivités territoriales et
c'est pour ça qu'on oppose sa
suppression
immédiatement et puis sur la tva
là aussi la tva sur le secteur de
l'hôtellerie de la restauration baisse
de tva non pas pour baisser les prix
il ya d'autres mesures pouvoir d'achat
mais là pour pouvoir reconstituer les
marges très rapidement toujours dans la
même logique il faut redonner de
l'oxygène aux entreprises pour qu'elles
puissent faire redémarrer
et puis dans ce volet également des
mesures spécifiques sur les jeunes
nous avons à voir on a sept cent mille
jeunes qui arrivent sur le marché du
travail dans trois semaines un mois
d'où la nécessité de les accompagner
dans les dans les meilleures conditions
et donc cette cette mesure qui
consistait une prise en charge de
salaire et ensuite des aides mais la
contrepartie c'est un cdi
parce que ça ne peut pas être dans un
système d'effet d'aubaine pour les
entreprises qui prend qu'il recruterait
des jeunes pour bénéficier des aides et
qui après les laisserait tomber pour en
reprendre d'hôtes donc la contrepartie
de ces mesures s'inscrivent bien dans la
logique de faire un contrat en cdi et
également des mesures spécifiques pour
une baisse de charge très significatif
de l'apprentissage savez que c'est un
sujet qui nous tient à coeur sur lequel
on a on est souvent intervenu et on
considère qu'il faut vraiment donner un
grand coup de pouce à l'apprentissage
avec du zéro charge la proposition c
zéro charges pour les entreprises qui
recrutent des jeunes en apprentissage
c'est aussi le moyen de mettre le pied
dans l'entreprise très rapidement et
puis dernier point sur ce volet qui est
qui est celui du temps de travail et de
l'annualisation du temps de travail
c'est une mesure qui a un double
avantage c'est à dire qu'à la fois elle
donne de la compétitivité à l'entreprise
et en même temps du pouvoir d'achat aux
salariés et on se situe au plus près
possible du bon de commande d'où la
nécessité d'avoir des accords en
entreprise il s'agit pas de faire un
grand accord national
on n'y arrivera pas et puis les
situations des entreprises sont très
différentes
donc c'est vraiment de la négociation
dans l'entreprise qui permet d'allonger
la durée du temps de travail dans le
cadre d'une annualisation est donc cette
mesure je vous dis à ce double effet
d'améliorer la compétitivité en
abaissant le coût du travail pour les
entreprises et d'augmenter le salaire
par l'augmentation des déserts
ensuite un deuxième volet sur le
restaurer notre souveraineté stratégique
lancé l'idée d'un da fond d'un fonds
souverain
ce fonds souverain pouvant intervenir en
prise de participation dans les
entreprises et sur les capitaux propres
il s'agit pas de refaire de la dette qui
va là aussi plombé les entreprises parce
que cette dette il faut la halle à
rembourser un jour et donc on continue à
maintenir les entreprises sous pression
là ça nous permet d'intervenir
directement sur les fonds propres et sur
le sur le haut de bilan
dans ce cadre là également une autre
mesure sur le crédit d'impôt de
relocalisation c'est un sujet sur lequel
on a beaucoup réfléchi on a d'ailleurs
auditionné bon c'est dans un autre cadre
d dans le cadre de nos forums
des entreprises qui ont fait le choix de
relocaliser certaines avaient délocalisé
en chine et ont relocalisé leur unité de
fabrication et donc il faut accompagner
des entreprises qui font qu'ils font ce
choix donc l'idée d'un crédit d'impôt
significative dans ce domaine à ce qui a
été mis en exergue dans la crise bon on
l'a tous noté 80% des substances actives
de nos médicaments sont faits hors des
frontières européennes
donc on voit bien tout l'intérêt qu'il y
a à voir dans ce domaine après bon je
prends pas toutes les mesures en détail
à vous les aurez sur le document mais
bâtir une économie plus juste là c'est
s'engager complètement dans la la
participation l'actionnariat salarié et
donc créer un vrai choc de
défiscalisation pour les entreprises qui
jouent le jeu de la la participation
avec également une exonération fiscale
pour les salariés qui en bénéficient
mais vraiment inciter les entreprises à
aller dans ce sens là et donc ça ça veut
dire qu'il faut faire sauter le forfait
social et donner un avantage fiscal à ce
qu'ils atteignent les 10% de
participation donc c'est une mesure très
très significative que on prend dans ce
cadre là aussi avec parallèlement à
cette notion d'une économie plus
demander comme ça a été expérimenté ce
que les bénéficiaires de rsa
puis se donner du temps pour travailler
dans les associations ou dans les dents
les collectivités et puis bien sûr le
plan de lutte contre la la fraude
sociale ensuite construire une économie
durable
c'est l'idée d'un grand plan de
rénovation énergétique
l'idée est d'aller de contribuer à la
fois à une baisse de la consommation
d'énergie
donc ce qui va bien sûr dans le bon sens
sur le plan environnemental qui se
traduit par des économies pour les
populations
et puis qui contribue à relancer
l'économie dans l'ain dans le secteur du
bâtiment et des travaux publics c'est à
dire que bon l'idée là on est plus sûr
du transfert de financement l'argent qui
aujourd'hui est mise sur les éoliennes
ou sur les panneaux photovoltaïques
pardon qui bien souvent sont fabriqués à
l'extérieur de nos frontières
européennes
la s'engager dans un grand plan
d'isolation du logement et qui
contribuera aussi au delà des économies
d'énergie et des bienfaits pour
l'environnement à créer de l'emploi dans
le web maintenir de l'emploi dans le
secteur du bâtiment et des tp et dernier
dernier point l'accès d'alimentation de
qualité
c'est un sujet qui est de plus en plus
sensible avec là aussi de mesures une
mesure pouvoir d'achat notamment sur les
les produits alimentaires de première
nécessité vont là aussi c'est déjà sorti
sur quelques ppl qu'on avait poussé et
puis également l'accompagnement sur les
circuits courts sur la vente directe est
aussi inciter les entreprises de
restauration collective notamment dans
le secteur public à faire du 100%
français du 100 % local
aujourd'hui par exemple dans la dernière
loi le gouvernement et on avait tenté de
s'y opposer impose un taux de bio
simplement il n'y a rien de me sur la
localisation
donc si c'est pour faire traverser
l'atlantique avec des certifications
discutable nous notre objectif c'est
vraiment de favoriser la production la
production locale
voilà le rapidement ce que vous
retrouverez dans notre préparation de
notre plan de relance
j'étais très bavard mais bon il ya
beaucoup de gens là qui sont à quillan
qui ont participé donc ce que je vous
propose peut-être c'est que les uns et
les autres puissent réagir depuis que
damien nous propose la deuxième phase
c'est-à-dire au-delà de la présentation
du plan relance on va le faire dans dans
les niches parlementaires les niches
parlementaires ont été arrêtés alors je
peux aussi avant peut-être guillaume et
aurélien veulent dire un mot damien va
vous montrer puis annie aller qui
commenteront qu'il y en a qui commence
bien juste quelques mots généraux pour
dire que ce programme de ce plan de
relance des républicains finalement il
clôt du moins je l'espère le débat est
de ceux qui voient une opposition entre
les tenants de l'orthodoxie budgétaire
économique et libérale et ceux qui ont
une approche plus sociale précisément ce
plan de relance ambitionne de les
montrer leur compatibilité non seulement
leur compatibilité mais leur nécessaire
dépendance l'une à l'autre
christian notre président a souvent
l'habitude de dire que les choses repose
sur un triptyque l'économie le social
l'environnemental
c'est exactement ce que contient ce plan
de relance et je crois qu'il ya là
quelque chose non seulement d'équilibrer
mais qui est destiné aussi à donner ce
qui est absolument indispensable en
matière d'économie de donner confiance
vous le savez sans confiance l'économie
ne peut pas fonctionner de façon
satisfaisante et je crois qu'il ya à la
fois quelque chose de
très sérieux de très travaillé dix avons
beaucoup réfléchi nous nous sommes
beaucoup inspirés aussi de ce que le
terrain révélé je terminerai en disant
que ce plan de relance s'inspire aussi
de ce que nous avons vécu pendant cette
crise et qui a révélé un certain nombre
d'enseignements tout d'abord la
restauration de la notion de nation en
matière économique ça a du sens le
l'attention que nous avons porté à la
jeunesse quand une corde complète
arrivent sur le marché de l'emploi sans
perspective de d'insertion
professionnelle il ya là quelque chose
d'absolument dramatique et il faut des
mesures incitatives extrêmement forte et
puis le troisième fut ce que je ferai
parce que mes collègues vont détailler
c'est la question de l'alimentation et
de l'agriculture
nous sommes très très regardant sur ce
qui va se passer en matière de politique
européenne vous avec la la possible
diminution du budget de la pac aura
certainement des incidences très forte
sur le monde agricole et c'est un point
de vigilance absolue
donc il faut à la fois combinés la
sécurité alimentaire le soutien apporté
à notre notre agriculture
et puis aussi faire prospérer la notion
d'une agriculture et d'une alimentation
la plus saine possible
voilà quelques focus que je voulais
faire sur ce plan de relance qui
contient énormément de mesures et je
crois vraiment qu'ils sont là le fruit
d'un travail et d'une crédibilité
certaine
voilà je remercie les paroles guillon
bon quelques mots tout a quasiment été
dit pour vous dire c'est d'abord un
immense travail collectif est ce que le
mot clé de cette journée c'est vraiment
le mot travail un travail collectif mené
par et autour de christian un élan
travail de coordination menée par par
aurélien avec nos groupes parlementaires
tous les députés autour de damiano
sénateurs autour de 2 bruno c'est un
travail unitaire qui révèle malgré ici
ou là les scepticismes des uns et des
autres notre capacité très forte au delà
des questions régaliennes sur les
questions économiques et sociales être
profondément unis et à marcher de
manière très claire sur deux piliers le
pilier des libertés économiques et le
pilier de la justice sociale l'un et
l'autre sont intimement liés et de dire
et de redire sans cesse c'est la
vocation est la colonne vertébrale de
notre famille politique que c'est par le
travail que nous pourrons redresser
notre pays c'est par le travail que
pourront soutenir nos entreprises c'est
par le travail que nous pourrons
rembourser notre dette c'est par le
travail que nous pourrons relancer la
croissance et qu'il n'ya pas
d'émancipation et de dignité d'avenir
pour notre pays
si la valeur travail ne redevient ne
revient pas là la valeur centrale et
cardinal de la société française et pour
ce faire
dans toutes les propositions qui ont été
faites et damien va y revenir à travers
manière très concrète des propositions
de lois tout au long des prochaines
semaines
vous avez deux marqueurs très clair la
baisse des impôts des charges et des
taxes d'une part et puis la hausse des
revenus d'autre part la baisse des
impôts des taxes c'est la baisse de la
tva c'est les crédits d'impôt pour les
relocalisations
c'est l'année blanche pour nos pme et
nos tpe sur le plan fiscal et social
et puis cette perspective ô combien
important de la participation c'est à
dire que le travail
oui et la récompense du travail à
travers une hausse des revenus on y
reviendra à travers nos propositions de
loi et ce sera pour conclure le grand
sujet de notre convention nationale de
la fin du mois de septembre et début du
mois d'octobre qui aura pour thème le
travail des salaires les revenus et le
pouvoir d'achat donc on reviendra en
long en large sur toutes ces mesures
concrètes
bonjour à toutes et à tous je n'ai pas
saluer quelques mots d'amour sur la
méthode et je vais insister chacun l'a
dit c'est l'ambition christian jacob a à
donner à notre famille politique en
arrivant dans cette maison permettre à
ce que nous revenions vers un travail de
fond d'ailleurs c'est ce qui nous permet
de nous rassembler pour être très clair
on peut multiplier les tribunes les
prises de position parfois fictivement
semblait s'opposer les uns les autres
dès lors qu'on se remet sur le fond
qu'on travaille véritablement à des
propositions on est capable de se réunir
et c'est ce point de méthodes que je
voulais d'abord faire parce que la
présentation de ce plan de relance qui
est un document solide fourni plein
d'imagination aussi dire qu'on n'a pas
des congés des vieilles mesure nous
aurions pu avoir depuis des années on
est allé sur des terrains assez nouveau
et on a expérimenté des propositions
nouvelles
tout cela a été fait de manière tout à
fait collective on a eu plusieurs heures
de réunion de travail
on sait confrontés les uns les autres de
nos points de vue et on a réussi à faire
émerger de véritables points de
consensus sans pour autant que ce soit
des propositions d'eau tiède et ça je
pense que c'est une leçon pour l'avenir
c'est le cas des forums qui se tiennent
depuis le début de l'installation de la
nouvelle équipe ici aux républicains et
cette démarche-là cette proposition
cette production là elle est le résultat
est la démonstration que les
républicains
profondément de travail avec un sens des
responsabilités tout à fait conscient
sur le fond l'equilibre que nous avons
voulu trouver c'est à la fois celui du
développement économique mais aussi
celui de la cohésion sociale
cet équilibre là c'est celui qui va nous
guider dans les mois et dans les années
qui viennent comme il nous a d'ailleurs
le plus souvent guidés par le passé dans
l'histoire de notre famille politique il
y a trois mesures qui à mon sens incarne
cet équilibre là cette complémentarité
là la première des mesures c'est celle
qui concerne la participation
nous avons dans notre pays un véritable
sujet avec le niveau des salaires
personne ne le conteste d'ailleurs
partout sur l'échiquier politique
dès lors il ya plusieurs propositions
possibles nous en avons retenu une
ambitieuse qui est celle de rénover
profondément l'idée de la participation
est consentant de bien il s'agit pas
comme on a pu le lire depuis quelques
jours de ressortir et d'agiter le mot de
participation sans rien changer
sans renouveler les idées et sans en
faire un véritable choc de l'évolution
des salaires et vous aurez dans vous
verrez dans ce plan qui vous est proposé
que nous avons travaillé profondément
sur la rénovation de l'idée de la
participation cette belle idée gaulliste
que nous voulons l'actualiser d'abord en
provoquant comme l'a dit christian un
véritable choc de défiscalisation on
sort de tous les débats sur la
fiscalisation de la participation et
l'intéressement et ont dit clairement
que en deçà de 3 smic
toutes les mesures de versement seront
défiscaliser autant pour les salariés
que pour les entreprises
vous voyez le parallèle d'ailleurs avec
ce que notre famille politique a pu
porter par le passé sur la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires et cette mesure là ce
n'est pas une mesure anecdotique c'est
une mesure qui fait débat mais qui pour
nous est une mesure tout à fait
audacieuse de la même manière on propose
de revoir fondamentalement les calculs
du mode de participation et
l'intéressement d'associer l'ensemble
des entreprises pour faire en sorte qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui que
l'intégralité des entreprises de notre
pays puissent débattre de la question de
la participation il ne faut pas que ce
soit seulement réservé aux grandes
entreprises et aux hauts revenus comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui
enfin sur la participation nous
explorons deux pistes majeures d'abord
l'extension de la participation au
secteur public
nous vivons aujourd'hui avec l'hôpital
pensons qu'il vaut mieux mieux rémunérer
les hospitaliers avec une évolution du
salaire par l'intéressement par
l'engagement qu'ils ont eue au service
de la nation
tous que le faire par des primes qui
sont tout à fait éphémère et puis nous
voulons l'élargir et c'est le chantier
que nous allons réouvrir un secteur
majeur qui suit la nouvelle économie
on ne peut pas penser la participation
demain si on ne l'appliquent pas aux
start-up notre pays qui sont un modèle
économique nouveau qui n'était pas pensé
par le général de gaulle à l'époque et
nous sommes en train de travailler sur
un sujet considérable qui vivent au
final de faire en sorte que l'ensemble
des concitoyens de notre pays puissent
demain être concerné par l'évolution par
la participation dernier mot d'une
seconde mesure à laquelle nous croyons
beaucoup c'est celle de l'alimentation
et quelques années peut-être que nous
n'aurions pas eu dans le plan de relance
économique des républicains un chapitre
entier sur l'alimentation
c'est à la fois la prise de conscience
du sujet stratégique que cela comporte
pour notre économie nationale aussi du
fait que c'est devenu un sujet crucial
pour nos concitoyens depuis plusieurs
mois de confinement a poussé à avoir un
rapport à l'alimentation différent on ne
peut pas le négliger
et la crise alimentaire qui s'approche
avec la baisse des revenus et certains
hausses de prix fait que nous devons
avoir des mesures fortes
la première de ces mesures consistent à
identifier mille produits de première
nécessité de production nationale et de
haute qualité nutritionnelle sur
lesquels nous proposons un taux marginal
de tva en contrepartie d'une
sécurisation des prix notamment dans la
grande distribution
pas de blocage et prix j'ai bien parlé
de sécurisation des prix c'est du
donnant donnant c'est une mesure tout à
fait forte de la même manière nous
allons au delà sur la question des
circuits courts et de la restauration
collective
l'ambition de 100% d'approvisionnement
en produits nationaux dans la
restauration collective c'est une
ambition considérable que personne n'a
osé jusque là et nous la posons ici
dernier mot d'une dernière mesure
laquelle je tiens et nous tenons
collectivement qui est celle de l'emploi
des jeunes sept cent mille jeunes
christian l'a dit tout à l'heure qui
arrivent sur le marché de l'emploi est
le danger colossal d'une génération
sacrifiée que chacun mesure bien mais je
sais que c'est le cas que la crise
économique sera doublée d'une crise
sociale décuplée et donc notre ambition
est d'avoir une mesure là aussi très
forte qui n'est pas timide sur la
question de l'emploi des jeunes un
dispositif de tremplin qui permet durant
les premiers mois une prise en charge
des salaires par l'état à des auteurs
qui sont à définir sûrement sur le
modèle du chômage partiel qui se suit
ensuite par deux années de
charge 0 pour les entreprises et qui se
conclut par l'engagement d'un contrat à
durée indéterminée pour les jeunes
simple parenthèse qui a des observateurs
avertis de notre vie politique et
quelques années on aurait proposé
d'autres dispositifs sur les jeunes
sûrement moins sécurisant aujourd'hui on
propose un dispositif qui est sécurisant
pour le début de l'an bosch qui est
sécurisant pour le cdi conviendrait que
les uns les autres
nous sommes aussi capables d'apprendre
du passé et de se projeter vers l'avenir
je conclus en vous disant que dans ce
plan il ya des mesures d'urgence mais
aussi ce qu'il faut surtout y lire c'est
les mesures d'avenir nous ouvrons des
pistes qui seront des chantiers pour
nous important
quant au débat politique à venir de
l'organisation de notre société et de
notre pays merci beaucoup bonjour à
toutes et à tous d'avoir peut-être
quelques mots pour dire que c'est quand
même le retour des républicains sur le
champ économique et social on l'a fait
notamment sur la réforme des retraites
il ya quelques temps nous l'avons fait à
l'assemblée nationale avec le plan de
déconfinement 72 heures avant celle du
gouvernement et nous faisons aujourd'hui
avec le plan de relance présenté par par
les républicains je crois que c'est très
important parce que on a eu parfois un
peu de prudence ou de pudeur en
considérant que c'était presque une
chasse gardée présidentielle on voit
aujourd'hui très clairement que
désormais notre rôle il aida les
challenges et la macro ni sur le plan
économique et social
le challenge est parce qu il ya beaucoup
de déçus parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'interrogations parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'incertitude et que le climat dans
lequel on est aujourd'hui inquiète et
interroge la deuxième remarque toujours
sur le plan politique c'est que nous
sommes dans la continuité de notre
volonté d'être une force de proposition
je crois que c'est une marque de
fabrique majeur de notre famille
politique que d'internés d' incarner une
alternance crédible qui soient une force
de proposition et qu'ils soient à chaque
fois en amont des débats et non pas en
aval en tant que tel devrait commencer à
dire que j'ai plus juste j'ai passé 48
heures
avec douze entreprises dans le
département de l'ain oyonnax douze
entreprises qui ont toutes su réagir par
rapport à la crise
certaines ont fabriqué des gels des
flacons de gel hydroalcoolique
nous avons d'ailleurs le numéro un
français dans l'ain d'autres ont fait
des systèmes de d'ouverture de fermeture
de porte son pouvoir les toucher
d'autres ont fait des masques
intelligent c'est à dire avec des
systèmes de filtration recyclables et
autres etc ou d'autres encore ont
développé des procédés sur par rapport
aux covit 19 tout ça pour vous dire quoi
que la première chose qui nous ont
demandé c'est de dire redémarrer
l'économie française redémarrer
l'économie française et faites nous
confiance pour cela et donc des confiné
et permettait le retour de nos salariés
dans nos entreprises
et je pense que c'est un enjeu majeur et
c'est ce sera d'ailleurs l'objet de la
première proposition de loi on débattra
dès le jeudi 11 juin qui est celle
justement qui va consister à
progressivement sortir du système de
chômage partiel qui comme l'a dit
christian a été efficace salué en tant
que tel mais qui ne peut être indéfinie
et surtout ne peut être durable et que
donc on propose cette sortie progressive
en contrepartie d'un allègement de
charges
pourquoi pour faire en sorte que quand
vous avez 40% 50% 60 % de votre chiffre
d'affaires que vous perdez et bien que
par l'allégement de charges on puisse
permettre aux entreprises de rester
ouverts tout en compensant ces coups là
et ça c'est une mesure très importante
parce que c'est une mesure de un espèce
de booster économique qui va permettre
justement aux entreprises de passer le
cap
d'éviter au maximum les licenciements
les plans sociaux et surtout de
permettre tout simplement de restaurer
la trésorerie en tant que tel et c'est
pour nous un point bien sûr très
important la deuxième chose qui nous ont
demandé c'est de dire je sais que les
débats sur le temps de travail anime
beaucoup essaient de dire laissez nous
faire au niveau des entreprises et je
pense doit être aussi notre message
politique à droite veut dire la question
n'est pas de savoir s'il faut revenir au
pas sur le cadre légal des 35m la
question elle est de laisser faire les
entreprises au niveau des entreprises
pourquoi parce que vous avez des
secteurs qui ont besoin de plus
demandeurs vous avez des secteurs en
forte tension qui
tt vont devoir mobiliser davantage leurs
salariés qui fait que certains d'entre
eux vont être beaucoup plus mobilisés
mais inversement vous allez avoir aussi
d'autres secteurs dans lequel
malheureusement
eh bien vous avez d'une diminution
centrale et dans ces entreprises que
j'ai visité certains ont supprimé
l'équipe de nuit
d'autres ont supprimé telle ou telle
activité et donc notre enjeu à nous
c'est de relancer justement l'activité
économique et de permettre ce lissage là
et donc notre deuxième proposition
elle vise justement à faire ce qu'on
appelait une année blanche en tout cas
une annulation des charges fiscales et
sociales
mais une annulation qui soit qui soit
totale pourquoi parce que jusqu'à
maintenant et je prends juste ce point
la nôtre suppression elle vise à toucher
toutes les charges sociales et fiscales
de toutes les entreprises qui ont perdu
au moins 50 % de leur chiffre d'affaires
cette suppression sera valable sur les
mois de mars avril mai juin et début
juillet voire au delà si jamais l'état
d'urgence devait se prolonger
donc l'objectif il n'est pas de d'être
comme le gouvernement dans des
animations spécifiques minime est
réduite mais d'être dans une montée de
supprimer les charges sociales et
fiscales et j'insiste bien sur et le et
fiscales ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui et ce sera l'objet de notre
deuxième proposition de loi qui elle
sera défendue par par daniel fasquelle
avant celle là nous avons une
proposition de loi qui visera et
guillaume en a parlé justement à
faciliter la question de l' embauche ou
en tout cas de l'arrivée sur le marché
travail des jeunes
sept cent mille jeunes vont arriver sur
le marché du travail sont beaucoup
d'inquiétude beaucoup d'interrogations
sur les capacités des entreprises à
maintenir les apprentis les stages les
jeunes en insertion également dans nos
entreprises en tant que tel est donc
l'objectif il sera tout simplement de
faire en sorte qu'on puisse est bien
exonéré 750 mille jeunes exonéré dont
toutes les charges sociales patronales
pendant deux ans pour toute embauche en
cdi d'un jeune de moins de 25 ans donc
annulé l'ensemble des charges sociales
patronales pendant deux ans pour toute
embauche en cdi d'un jeune de moins de
25 ans c'est une
proposition de loi bien sûr important
importante mais qu'il nous faudra faire
face pour tout simplement éviter que ce
soit une génération sacrifiée en tant
que tel ensuite la quatrième proposition
de loi sera sur la tva à 5,5 tout le
monde en a parlé
juste un mot sur la philosophie de cette
proposition parce que vous savez que
c'est une proposition qui avait été
faite à l'époque de nicolas sarkozy
simplement vous dire que la philosophie
n'est pas la même pourquoi parce que à
l'époque quand elle a été faite d'abord
à l'été sur un caractère durable elle
était faite pour baisser les prix ou
augmenter les emplois
là nous sommes dans une proposition de
baisse de tva à 5 5 % de manière
transitoire jusqu'à la fin de l'année
qui a un seul objectif c'est permettre
au café et au restaurant qu'ils ont
réouvert aujourd'hui de pouvoir perdurer
dans le temps et que l'on évite tout
simplement que les terrasses qui sont
ouvertes aujourd'hui soit fermée demain
est donc l'enjeu pour ça c'est de
permettre une mesure une forte mesure de
trésorerie et donc la forte mesures de
trésorerie c'est de dire voilà on vous
demande pas de baisser les prix on vous
demande pas de créer des emplois
supplémentaires
simplement comme vous allez faire 40 50
60 % de votre chiffre d'affaires eh bien
on vous propose que sur ces 40 50 60 %
du chiffre d'affaires vous ayez un bonus
économique avec l'abaissement de la tva
et donc c'est à titre transitoire et
s'est fait justement pour préserver tout
simplement ce tissu essentiel des cafés
et des restaurants
comme vous le savez enfin deux dernières
propositions de loi une qui vise à
évoquer la question de la
décentralisation
parce que je crois que aussi dans ce
plan de relance le plan de relance ne
fonctionnera que si on fait confiance
aux collectivités locales et aux
collectivités de proximité et c'est
essentiel que les départements les
régions les intercommunalités joue un
rôle central
on aura certainement un débat où une
proposition de loi sur la
décentralisation on propose en tout cas
d'amorcé la discussion notamment pour
permettre au département et bien de
bénéficier de la compétence économique
et la compétence surtout tourisme à un
moment où le tourisme qui est une
compétence partagée a besoin d'être de
tout le monde je pense au secteur
l'hôtellerie la restauration n'est pas
simplement vous avez les campings vous
avez les chambres d'hôtes c'est toutes
les aides diverses et variées et ça me
semble important que toutes les
collectivités locales
on a vu leur agilité
leur efficacité nous sommes aussi le
parti de la décentralisation et donc on
doit accompagner ces collectivités et
leur permettre d'agir au quotidien
notamment pour soutenir le secteur et la
filière tourisme tourisme culture en
terre et enfin dernier dernier point que
nous défendrons donc sur 7 sur la
question de la tva restauration c'est de
le dire mais c'est brigitte kuster donc
cutter qui sera le nôtre notre notre
rapporteur
et puis avec emilie bonnivard et ensuite
donc pour laquelle la proposition de loi
qui relevait donc de des départements et
dans des collectivités territoriales
c'est pierre cordier qui sera le
rapporteur et enfin sur la dernière donc
c'est eric straumann qui la dernière et
vise à s'inscrire dans ce que le parti a
fait sur la question de l'alimentation
notamment
c'est à dire augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat des français et en supprimant la
tva sur les achats de masques et de gel
hydroalcoolique donc c'est la tva à 0%
pour tous les achats de masques et gels
hydroalcooliques il nous pendre il nous
semble important en tout cas que l'on
puisse et bien permettre cela et l'accès
massif à 7 à la population en tant que
telle à ses besoins donc voilà comment
on a construit cette journée du 11 juin
donc se dire va faire l'objet de débats
en commission cette semaine la semaine
prochaine en suit donc nous aurons des
votes dans l'hémicycle et eh bien nous
verrons et nous verrons si bien le
souffle finalement et bien ce sera là ou
pas et si la majorité est prête à voter
ou pas un certain nombre de dispositifs
et de proposition de loi que nous
présentons au nom du groupe l'est
républicain la mise des comptes publics
avait dit que pour éteindre l'incendié
fallait pas compter ses litres d'eau je
crois effectivement que en tout cas il
faut pas éteindre l'incendié avec un
arrosoir et qu'il est essentiel pour
nous de donner les moyens de tout ça et
j'en terminerai par là je conclurai par
là je crois que c'est très important
qu'on donne une cohérence d'ensemble
assez à ces propositions
elles ont toutes le même objectif c'est
de dire la relance économique ne se fera
pas sur le dos du pouvoir d'achat des
salariés
elle se fera avec eux et elle se fera en
accompagnant et en aidant financièrement
socialement et fiscalement nos
entreprises qui sont les moteurs de cela
et d'ailleurs ce qui nous interpelle
c'était espèce de deux plans de relance
comme un espèce de millefeuille de la
relance moi je ne crois pas ce
millefeuille dans lequel on saucissonne
les filières les zones à côté des autres
où on va injecter un peu sur la filière
automobile ensuite sur la filière
aéronautique ensuite sur telle ou telle
filière je pense qu'il faut aussi une
vue d'ensemble et que c'est très
important de défendre notre politique
industrielle et nous et nos fleurons
industriels voilà un peu l'objectif de
cette journée notamment
est-ce que vous avez des questions ou on
reste tout cela j'ai juste une question
sur la participation qui sera donc pas
abordé le 11 juin si j'ai bien compris
est ce que ça veut dire que vous
pourriez envisager d'y travailler avec
le ministre effectivement vous avez
abordé rapidement qu'il lui en a fait un
de ses possibles chantier alors sur la
participation
bon nous on y travaille dans un cadre
plus large que celui des forums et
guillaume évoqué tout à l'heure à la
fois les salaires et le revenu des
entreprises
donc c'est dans ce cadre là nous on va
continuer dessus on verra bien à la
rentrée lorsqu'on va avoir notre
convention dessus ceci étant
à chaque fois qu'on aura l'occasion on y
reviendra sur par voie d'amendement mais
on n'est pas dans la même logique on
n'est pas sur des ajustements c'est ce
que aurélien expliqué tout à l'heure
l'idée c'est vraiment de créer un grand
choc est aujourd'hui le forfait social
c'est 20% sur les montants reversés en
participation pour les entreprises c'est
de supprimer ces de défiscaliser
également là pour les salariés qui en
bénéficient
la participation c'est de mettre un
avoir fiscal pour les entreprises qui
atteignent le taux de 10%
donc on on verra ce qui met nous on met
des mesures concrètes sur la table donc
on verra
bonjour il ya plusieurs mesures vous
l'avez un petit peu évoqué les uns et
les autres qui ont été qui sont nés
d'une réflexion pendant pendant la crise
sur ce qui est arrivé de façon plus
large
est ce que les uns les autres et vous en
premier christian jacob la crise et la
réflexion qu'elle a pu qu'elle a pu
susciter a pu ébranler des choses plus
profondes et des certitudes est ce qu'il
ya des choses que vous avez pu sur
lesquels vous avez pu vraiment
complètement changé d'avis complètement
variés ou prendre un virage à 180 juste
pas non virage à 180 degrés n'ont en
revanche il ya certain nombre de choses
qu'on ressentait mais qui ont été mis en
exergue comme souvent en nouant des
crises le sujet de la relocalisation
c'est objectivement un sujet sur lequel
on travaillait dans nos forums et qu'on
avait mis en priorité mais la la la la
crise l'a mis en exergue je cite l
exemple sur le médicament
on peut regarder sur l'alimentation on
avait évoqué sa en début d'année ou à
l'occasion d'une conférence de presse
sur les le budget agricole
j'expliquais le risque que l'on avait de
devenir déficitaire sur de perdre
l'autosuffisance alimentaire déjà
aujourd'hui si vous retirez les vins et
spiritueux dans notre balance
commerciale agroalimentaire on
s'aperçoit qu'on est déficitaire
donc on voit bien l'intérêt n'est sûr
ensuite les changements de consommation
aurélien il fait allusion tout à l'heure
on voit bien que cette période de crise
de confinement a modifié à modifier les
choses
tout le monde voit l'intérêt au delà du
tout bio c'est aussi de penser local et
de dire que on peut se mettre et ce qui
a été mis dans la loi on l'avait
d'ailleurs combattu à l'époque d'obliger
dans les cantines la restauration
collective aux 20% de bio
si c'est pour faire venir du bio par par
cargo avec un coût carbone énorme et des
certifications dont on n'est pas sûr on
préfère être sur une agriculture
raisonnée est sûre du bio mais sur la
production locale donc ça c'est un sujet
qui était qu'on ressentait depuis le
début mai la crise en a mis
effectivement un certain nombre en
exergue indiscutablement quand vous
dites travail négociée annualisé est ce
que ça peut vouloir dire moins de congés
par exemple comme l'ont un peu évoqués
comme l'a évoqué certains au medef
moi je suis pas là dessus je suis sur le
fait on est à 1607 heures aujourd'hui de
temps de travail si on est sur la souris
zone sur les 35 heures c'est de dire
entre 1600 et 1800 heures la négociation
dans l'entreprise au plus près du bon de
commande
c'est à dire qu'il ya des moments damian
a évoqué où il faut mettre
l'accélérateur parce qu'il ya une
situation
le carnet de commandes se remplit
d'autres moments effectivement ou celles
les moins donc on est cette souplesse et
que ce soit fait dans un cadre de
négociations donc l'entreprise ou les
branches
quand on est sur des entreprises de très
faible très faible taille mais on on
peut réfléchir aussi de la même manière
dans le secteur public
on voit bien qu'il y a besoin de cette
souplesse qui doit s'accompagner
d'ailleurs d'autonomie de davantage
d'autonomie dans le dans les
établissements publics de façon à
pouvoir jouer avec le terrain c'est ça
l'objectif n'y a pas de dogme
moi je ne crois pas à dire faut
supprimer 30 jours de congés etc
mais je pense qu'il faut être dans la
négociation est encore une fois on doit
s'adapter
notre réglementation doit s'adapter à la
situation de l'économie c'est pas l'un
vers ce certaines y ont cru mais ça
marche pas on est à peu près à 10% du
pib c'est-à-dire de 150 milliards
d'euros sur ce qui est pour
voyez on avait une discussion à bâtons
rompus ce matin je disais finalement
c'est c'est l'excédent s'est pas plus
que l'excédent de la balance commerciale
annuelle de l'allemagne un élément de
comparaison
c'est même moins parce que l'allemagne
doit être à 300 milliards d'excédents sa
balance commerciale
on est sur un plancher autour de 250 et
quand on met en face de cela les mesures
que l'on avait déjà proposé dans la loi
de finances l'année dernière de
d'économie la lutte contre les fraudes
fiscales mais surtout sociale la con on
évoque à nouveau et puis la relance de
consommation je pense que l' équilibre
peut tout à fait se se trouvait est-ce
qu'on peut profiter pour vous poser des
questions sur autre chose
j'ai notamment une commande dans la
collecte des arbres à propos de demain
sur la l'installation de la commission
d' enquête qui sera président et je
crois par richard ferrand est-ce que du
coup les dés sont pas un peu pipés
d'avancé je veux
vous en dire un mot mais j'ai surtout
laissé damien non pas botter en touche
mais c'est plus le boulot de président
de groupe sur ce sujet bon moi je sais
pas ce que fera le président de
l'assemblée nationale
je pense que ça n'est sans doute pas
l'idéal que ce soit lui qui l'a qui la
préside
mais ce sera sa décision simplement
l'assemblée a un devoir de vérité et
d'objectivité sur sur ce travail et
vouloir mettre le sujet sous l'étouffoir
et c'est quand même ce que l'on a senti
dans un premier temps de la part de
d'origine de richard ferrand et de la
majorité on a vu comment sa tournée pour
la faire benalla personne n'y gagne une
commission denquête c'est un travail
sérieux qui doit se faire avec rigueur
avec sang froid et avec objectivité et
j'espère qu'on va retrouver sam est vrai
que bon damien tu veux non simplement
bon d'abord moi on n'est pas là pour
faire le casting n'a vu qu'en marge donc
c'est à eux de désigner leur président
mais enfin de tout devrait selon toute
vraisemblance ça ne sera pas le
président de l'assemblée nationale qui
présiderait la commission denquête donc
pour qu'on soit bien clair
7 la mission d'information qui se
transforme en commission denquête donc à
partir de demain 15 heures nous nous
avions une double demande ce qu'a dit
christian c'est d'abord voulu en
équilibre entre la majorité et
l'opposition
il est hors de question de participer à
une commission denquête qui sont entre
les mains d'un seul majorité et donc à
partir de là les équilibres politiques
il ne pouvait se faire qu'avec la
présidence et le rapporteur généraux le
général pardon et la répartition des
vice présidences dans le bureau aussi ce
qui sera un peu lol le coeur du réacteur
de la commission denquête et donc à
partir de là nous avons donc
effectivement pour républicain le poste
de rapporteur général et un poste de
vice président et donc c'est ce que nous
désignerons demain puisque demain nous
voterons officiellement en tout cas
désigne officiellement le président des
vice président et le rapporteur général
et donc je peux vous dire que c'est que
ce sera de notre côté que le rapport
ajoutait en général sera du côté des
républicains
la deuxième chose c'est que ensuite une
fois que nous aurons installer cette
commission denquête c'est à dire demain
à 15h mur à camon vote avant à
l'assemblée nationale puisque une
commission denquête des communistes sur
le même champ d'application y aura un
vote tout à l'heure ensuite eh bien elle
pourra démarrer ses travaux quand elle
souhaite vraisemblablement mais ça c'est
un calendrier à finir avec le ou la
future présidente de la commission aussi
avec un listing des auditions ça devrait
normalement débuter autour de mi juin
donc sachant que le sénat a prévu de
démarrer ses travaux fin juin donc voilà
on à peu près dans ce cadre là
maintenant il reste à définir le
calendrier des auditions la main ça se
passe et pour nous c'est très important
cette commission denquête elle soit ni
un tribunal populaire on cherche une
réalité judiciaire ni un endroit où on
met la poussière sous le tapis
l'enjeu pour nous c'est clairement de
voir le dysfonctionnement les
défaillances et les failles et si jamais
votre collègue d'euros peuvent
poursuivre là dessus vous invite à lire
un excellent journal d'après midi kelly
a touché la commission d'un cadeau
merci
il n'y a pas du tout des d'erreur
d'erreur local simplement ils relèvent
d'un consensus et d'un accord local
s'engage absolument pas je les dis un
accord politique nationale on n'est pas
du tout dans ce cadre là ce sont tout
simplement les élus de la métropole
lyonnaise qui ont décidé de se
rassembler autour de françois noël
buffet à partir du moment où gérard
collomb s'était retirée et de se
rassembler autour de lui pour porter un
projet qui est effectivement à l'opposé
de celui qui est porté par l'extrême
gauche et les verts parce que le projet
sur la métropole lyonnaise c'est
l'extrême gauche et les verts
donc on n'est pas on n'a pas beaucoup de
points de convergence même aucun avec
monsieur mélenchon ni avec les verts
dans la proche qui est la leur qui quand
même on est là avec des verres très très
rouge et donc l'ensemble des élus
territoriaux se sont regroupés autour de
françois noël buffet et voilà moi ce que
je souhaite c'est bien évidemment la
victoire de françois noël buffet mais ça
n'est pas un accord national et c'est
pour ça que j'avais souhaité le marquer
dès le départ
or écouter sur les 5000
déjà il ya trente mille villes qui ont
été élus le maire qui ont été élus sur
sur 35 mille trente mille l'on était
posé aucun problème il n'y a pas eu vous
appelez d'accords locaux
ensuite sur les 5000 qui reste je pense
que s'ils tentaient qu' il y en ait qui
se bouclent ce sera moins ça ce contrat
sur les doigts d'une main et encore à
peine oui on parle si vous faites
référence à bordeaux je sais pas les
choses sont pas faites
mais par exemple c'est le maire de
bordeaux qui est les républicains
conserve sa majorité absolue semble
important écoutez là c'est plutôt le
sentiment du contraire non il y en a qui
est quand même un peu plus en tête que
l'autre non mais coûteux
on a la chance d'avoir un excellent
maire à bordeaux avec nicolas florian je
suis convaincu qu'on va conserver
si certains ont décidé de le rejoindre
voilà c'est leur force et leur décision
mais ce qui compte c'est que nicolas
florian sur son projet et sur sa
majorité conserve la majorité absolue
dans son conseil municipal ce qui je
crois sera au non non ce qui
compliquerait ses compères bordeaux
croyez-moi ça complique pas du tout j'en
aurai plus à 18 heures à ce stade non
moi je souhaite vraiment qu'il y ait un
rassemblement autour de martine vassal
martine vassal et seuls aujourd'hui qui
peut gagner j'ai regretté que bruno
gilles fois présenté comme candidat
dissident maintenant le premier tour est
derrière nous donc il est temps de se
rassembler et là aussi l'enjeu c'est si
ça n'est pas martine vassal c'est c'est
monsieur mélenchon et ses amis donc moi
j'appelle tout le monde à la
responsabilité sur le fait se rassembler
autour des listes
et d'ailleurs on a une conférence de
presse commune sur la proposition qui
avait été faite par une au mieux lier
renaud muselier martine vassal ont fait
leur conférence de presse ensemble et
c'est une bonne chose ça va dans le bon
sens maintenant vous savez pour avoir
l'expérience de mer tant que la liste
allait pas déposé lé pas déposé et là il
y en a plusieurs à déposer en
l'occurrence puisque c'est pas un
arrondissement secteur
on va voir on va voir moi j'ai eu
plusieurs
plusieurs maires on va voir si
dans quelles conditions ça peut se faire
et ça se fait bondir un peu plus tard
mais à ce stade on avait tout bloqué on
a même écarté complètement l'hypothèse
du fait des mesures de confinement bon
ben là on va voir comment les choses
vont bouger mais ce sera les discussions
de la semaine prochaine et vous savez
moi je crois vraiment que une excision
local c localement que ça se gagne
et j'ai eu la chance d'être élue et
réélue maire avec plutôt de bons
résultats et j'ai c'est vraiment
localement qu'on le fait quoi c'est pas
je crois pas beaucoup
n'empêche pas de faire des déplacements
mais dix ans que je pense que c'est sur
le terrain sur le projet et sur la
personnalité de nos candidats c'est
comme ça qu'on dit c'est bon pas de
question rentrée personne de frustrer
tout va bien